[Música]
en medio del combate aereo un mac 1.5 y
con una buena dosis de adrenalina en
venas para transporte de tropas
y suministros a
afganistán donde el ártico o 12 metros
desde la superficie del Atlántico Norte hasta el
buscar un submarino hostil o
de un pesquero en dificultad
somos las alas de canada
soy el capitan carlos oliva de
montreal soy piloto 16.8 en 3ro
escuadrón bagatela yo soy el
capitán philippe del líder cubano
transporte fidel aquí espero que a los 37
a los 30 años y soy el primer capitan
belanger
de la minerve en quebec
piloto de helicóptero en el escuadrón 4.23
en walter en nueva escocia
una picadura a las 11 a las 2 queria ser piloto
puede ser un poco gracioso
di pero la película top gun mi poquito
dirigido al lado de los pilotos de combate
savalas coulthard l atripla trabajar en
otro sentimiento
voy a tener como 7 u 8 años tuvimos
dar un paseo en helicóptero
me marcó porque siempre tuve
una fascinación por el helicóptero
desde este momento la provincia tiene la
privilegio de robar una región también
más grande que éste en la vida civil se necesita un
poco varios años logró una buena
veinteañeros así que estaba muy mimado eso es
muy emocionante, entonces siempre estoy listo para
volarlos como pilotos militantes
canadienses
nuestras misiones son tan variadas como las
copiloto de aeronave la habilidad que tiene
con la 18c podemos hacer misiones
defensa aérea para norad
es decir vamos a defender un
territorio podemos hacer misiones
ofensivos, es decir, para neutralizarlos
objetivos también tenemos misiones de
apoyo y nada que ayude
tropas de amigos sobre el terreno para luchar contra el
insurgentes
en lo que a mi concierne si voy a ser piloto
mi dia perfecto
ya sea para reponer otro
citación al orden cerca del ponant en
patrulla marítima con la roja o
todavía en larga distancia y un pato
con una nueva rotación de fuerza
luchador ya que militar quiero
di muévete así que necesitamos esto
ambos se mueven eficientemente y
rápido
en términos del instrumento rbc
que a los 37 han hecho mucho más que
el transporte de pasajeros no es demasiado
cristal
como piloto de helicóptero ta
misión hoy pretende traer
ayuda humanitaria en haití o
realizar una operación de búsqueda
y rescate en la costa
canadiense
apoyo a pilotos de helicópteros
grandes operaciones navales y
fuerza terrestre
nuestro papel aquí en 12 Wing es
apoyar a la marina canadiense para la
desempeñar una función de vigilancia de la superficie
submarinos de vigilancia o de superficie
así como los diferentes roles de
patrulla marítima por ejemplo
vigilar las zonas de pesca no
necesario para ser un piloto con licencia o incluso
tener su maestría para ti
únete a nuestras tripulaciones
las fuerzas se hicieron cargo del entrenamiento en
tierra y en el aire
mi sueño de ser piloto me llevó a
universidad militar real en kingston
ontario no necesita graduarse de
sus manos para volar con nosotros a través de
contra ella es necesario tener una buena visión
buena condición física y buena
reflejos
según programa tan de una rotación en
como aspirante a piloto entras
las fuerzas con el rango de
segundo teniente donde ella es viuda si él
se realiza en déficit de curso elemental en
quebec
también ves tomando cursos
Instructivo de héroe médico y de supervivencia
en el medio marino y terrestre después o
manitoba toma entrenamiento de vuelo
elemental en aviones
entrenamientos sofisticados como el
grueso
luego están los cursos elementales
y entrenamiento de vuelo superior
en aveyron ocho meses en saskatchewan en
manitoba con varios aviones modernos
Las instalaciones de las fuerzas están al final.
de última generación con simulador
entrenamiento ultra realista primero
clase
rendimiento en la escuela primaria y
las necesidades de las fuerzas determinan dos
realizado por primera vez en el plano de sion desde
cazando un viejo helicóptero multimotor
o incluso instructor de vuelo
no todos inician comandos
del avión de combate 40 millones
dolares
pero todos los que tienen su certificado de
piloto siente el mismo orgullo
las primeras veces que vi
el avión entonces eso fue todo lo que
podría pasar es wow es
trippy es excelente es
Increíble potencia de motor es
increíble todo el armamento todo eso
Puedo hacer con el avión en el
madrigueras hace unos 4-5 años visité
aumento de 40 50 países
Fui al norte de la rop
África
por lo que fue oportunidades el maestro
viajó y trabajó en vano en
combinación amarilla y a las comunidades i
Creo que también me gustaría el hecho de que
Nunca me he pillado en una oficina.
siempre una buena vista siempre lo hace
la habitación es de 35 desde el pie el entusiasmo de
Little Fly Kid todavía está allí, es
seguro que la pasión sigue ahí es necesario
verla en solo un montón de
trabajar
volar un helicóptero en
el escombro para robar no me canso
remanente para mí en metal
también se trata de ir a donde quieras
luego usar a los amigos como un
extensión de su cuerpo su significado un
libertad de tener la máquina al final de
sus pies y sus manos y hacer poco
cerca de lo que quieres con
[Música]